Shure:  这个地就跟我水土不服
Shure: This place just doesn't agree with me.
Alice:更喜欢猫还是狗
Alice: Do you prefer cats or dogs?
其他人：这不好说
Others: That's hard to say.
Alice:哦快快快快看
Alice: Oh, quick, quick, look!
Katrina:  这个叫什么
Katrina: What's this called?
Jake: 拍一个跟他们斗舞
Jake: Take a video of them dancing.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:  啊哈
Lucia: Aha.
Katrina:  这不是空竹吧
Katrina: This isn't a diabolo, right?
Jake: 斗是什么
Jake: What kind of dance?
Lucia:  好厉害啊
Lucia: So impressive!
Katrina:  我们特别像一群异类入侵
Katrina: We look like a bunch of aliens invading.
Katrina:  那边走走看
Katrina: Let's go over there and see.
其他人：哎你好这个叫什么啊
Others: Hey, what's this called?
其他人：这叫花棍
Others: It's called a flower stick.
Alice:花棍
Alice: Flower stick.
Jake: 花棍
Jake: Flower stick.
Alice:其他人：
Alice: Others:
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  这么多鱼
Katrina: So many fish.
Katrina:  哎你看
Katrina: Hey, look.
Katrina:  这一片红的全是鱼
Katrina: This whole red area is all fish.
其他人：哇真的啊
Others: Wow, really?
Katrina:  哇这是一个风水宝地
Katrina: Wow, this is a feng shui treasure land.
Katrina:  这么多鱼
Katrina: So many fish.
其他人：他要去干啥要丢一个珠子下去
Others: What's he going to do, throw a bead in there?
Katrina:  道歉呢
Katrina: To apologize?
Katrina:  这根本太抽象了
Katrina: This is just too abstract.
其他人：表情都不对了
Others: His expression is all wrong.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: You're killing me with laughter.
Katrina:  哎这咋玩
Katrina: Hey, how do you play this?
Alice:我能看下你是怎么开始的吗
Alice: Can I watch you start?
其他人：可以这这不这不是拿下来都会
Others: Can this be taken down?
其他人：你就得练
Others: You just have to practice.
Jake: 好离谱的数据我靠
Jake: Wow, these ridiculous numbers!
其他人：你要是想练这个
Others: If you want to practice this,
其他人：就是从这个基础学起
Others: you need to start from the basics.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:这样起来的
Alice: It starts like this.
其他人：掌握这个平衡
Others: Master this balance.
Lucia:  哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:哦这样起来的
Alice: Oh, it starts like this.
其他人：这这样调
Others: Adjust like this.
其他人：能调你就调
Others: Adjust if you can.
其他人：偏过中心就行
Others: Just past the center is fine.
其他人：偏过中心
Others: Just past the center.
Alice:我能使两个棍弄起来吗
Alice: Can I use two sticks?
Lucia:  我
Lucia: I...
Jake: 你厉害
Jake: You're awesome!
其他人：不要转这毛
Others: Don't spin this fur.
Shure: 不好意思不好意思
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 这毛
Jake: This fur.
其他人： 这就跟头发一样
Others: It's just like hair.
Jake: 这自怎么自己做的
Jake: Did you make this yourself?
Jake: 外边买
Jake: Bought it outside?
其他人： 开始时买的现在我自己做也卖
Others: I bought it at first, now I make and sell it myself.
Jake: 哦哦哦也卖哦
Jake: Oh, oh, you sell them too!
Jake: 要不咱两个扔试试
Jake: How about we both try throwing?
Jake: 哎呦厉害
Jake: Wow, impressive!
其他人： 两个的比一个的难度大多了
Others: Two sticks are much harder than one.
其他人： 因为是一个左手一个右手
Others: Because one is for the left hand, one is for the right hand.
Jake: 这两个棍
Jake: These two sticks.
Jake: 两两两个棍两个棍
Jake: Two, two sticks, two sticks.
其他人： 哦两个棍
Others: Oh, two sticks.
Jake: 两个棍容易一点
Jake: Two sticks are easier.
其他人： 这你也就看看热闹你如果想学这个从这个基础学起
Others: You should just watch for fun. If you want to learn this, start from the basics.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah!
Jake: 转起来了
Jake: It's spinning now!
Jake: 就刚刚刚刚那一段
Jake: Just that bit earlier.
Jake: 然后就重复剪出来
Jake: Then just repeat and edit it out.
Jake: 重复你就一直转
Jake: Just keep spinning it over and over.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake: 哈哈哈GIF出来了
Jake: Haha, the GIF is out.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, that's fine.
Jake: 够剪了够剪了够剪了
Jake: That's enough for editing, enough for editing.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Katrina:  走吧下一个景
Katrina: Let's move to the next scene.
Jake: 走吧下一个
Jake: Let's go to the next one.
Jake: 我们最后转到原来的位置
Jake: We'll end up back where we started.
Jake: 这样整个公园就重建出来了
Jake: That way, the whole park will be recreated.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 这地方克我
Shure: This place curses me.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 这地方就不吉利克我
Shure: This place just brings bad luck to me.
Shure:  我刚才给我女朋友发那个照片
Shure: I just sent a photo to my girlfriend.
Shure:  怎么感觉这好熟悉
Shure: She said this looks really familiar.
Shure: 她把之前跟他前男友遛狗的那个叫他
Shure: She said she used to walk her dog with her ex-boyfriend around here.
Shure: 她那个前男友家好像在这附近
Shure: Her ex-boyfriend's house seems to be nearby.
Shure: 她说这是不是6号线哪哪哪哪个站
Shure: She asked if this was near the 6th line, some station.
Shure: 哪个站
Shure: Some station.
Katrina:  哎呦
Katrina: Oh wow.
Katrina:  前男友显灵了
Katrina: Ex-boyfriend's spirit is here.
Shure:  他说没事
Shure: She said it's fine.
Shure:  给你挡灾了
Shure: She said it's protecting me.
Shure:  还好有这个事顶一下不然就会被骂
Shure: At least this happened, otherwise, I would have been scolded.
Katrina:  也可以往里走哎往里走
Katrina: We can also go inside, let's go inside.
Alice:禁止钓鱼
Alice: No fishing allowed.
Katrina:  这里好多鱼啊
Katrina: There are so many fish here.
Katrina:  明明感觉水质不是特别好
Katrina: The water doesn't even look that clean.
Katrina:  刚刚那里好多
Katrina: There were so many just now.
Katrina:  这是柳絮吧是不是
Katrina: Is this willow fluff or what?
Katrina:  怎么会这么多鱼啊
Katrina: Why are there so many fish?
Katrina:  感觉这水质不是特别好
Katrina: The water doesn't look that clean.
Shure:  水却清澈无鱼
Shure: Clear water has no fish.
Lucia:  可能他有点富营养化吧
Lucia: Maybe it's a bit eutrophic.
其他人：好专业啊
Others: So professional!
Lucia:  啊没有
Lucia: Ah, no.
Shure:  水太清就没吃的了
Shure: When water is too clear, there's nothing to eat.
Lucia:  我乱说的
Lucia: I was just making stuff up.
Lucia:  就是因为它有点发绿
Lucia: It's because it's kind of green.
Katrina:  好厉害啊
Katrina: That's amazing.
Katrina:  往上面面走走看
Katrina: Let's go up there and take a look.
Shure:  就是这吧
Shure: It's here, right?
Lucia:  或许地理课上吗
Lucia: Maybe in geography class?
Katrina:  北京瀑布
Katrina: Beijing waterfall.
Shure:  你带了头盔
Shure: You brought a helmet.
Shure:  可是没有插上
Shure: But it's not plugged in.
Jake: 一会再插
Jake: We'll plug it in later.
Jake: 刚刚其实应该插一下
Jake: Actually, we should have plugged it in just now.
Jake: 他一次只能录25分钟
Jake: It can only record for 25 minutes at a time.
Jake: 我要找到25分钟的那个时间段
Jake: I need to find that 25-minute segment.
Jake: 刚刚那段其实挺好的忘了
Jake: That last part was actually pretty good, but we forgot.
Lucia: 严谨
Lucia: Meticulous.
Jake: 看下一段
Jake: Let's look at the next part.
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Katrina:  这个树我从来没见过
Katrina: I've never seen this tree before.
Alice:好漂亮好漂亮
Alice: So beautiful, so beautiful.
Katrina:  拍出来有点没那么好看
Katrina: It doesn't look as good in the photo.
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha:  那我给你摘一片你吃吧
Tasha: Then I'll pick a leaf for you to eat.
Shure:  哦有蛤蟆
Shure: Oh, there's a toad.
Jake: 呵呵是这个意思
Jake: Haha, that's what it means.
Jake: 呵呵来给我试叶子可能是
Jake: Haha, come and try the leaf, maybe.
Tasha:  这个
Tasha: This one.
Shure:  我说我说这里面有蛤蟆啊叫了
Shure: I said, I said there's a toad in here, it's calling.
Shure:  听到了蟾蜍的叫声
Shure: I heard the sound of a toad.
Shure:  稍微践踏一下
Shure: Step on it a bit.
Jake: 找手串呢
Jake: Looking for the bracelet.
Shure:  我听到了
Shure: I heard it.
Shure:  哈哈蛤蟆听取蛙声一片
Shure: Haha, toad listening to the sound of frogs.
Katrina:  嗯这个好看
Katrina: Hmm, this one looks good.
Katrina:  水至清则无鱼
Katrina: If the water is too clear, there will be no fish.
Katrina:  人至贱则无敌
Katrina: If a person is too cheap, they are invincible.
Katrina:  这谁说来着
Katrina: Who said that?
Katrina:  谁说的
Katrina: Who said it?
Katrina:  怎么会突然出现在我的脑子里
Katrina: Why did it suddenly pop into my head?
Shure:  这是国宝特工
Shure: It's from National Treasure Agents.
Shure:  是吧你小时候看过吗
Shure: Right? Did you watch it when you were a kid?
Katrina:  是的看过
Katrina: Yes, I've watched it.
Shure:  然后那个
Shure: And then that...
Katrina:  陈留香说是不是
Katrina: Chen Liuxiang said, right?
Shure:  不是是那个戴一个眼罩的那个
Shure: No, it's the one with an eye patch.
Lucia:  哦然后进水就坏了是吗
Lucia: Oh, and it broke when water got in, right?
Katrina:  水至清则无鱼
Katrina: When water is too clear, there are no fish.
Katrina:  人至贱则无敌
Katrina: When a person is too cheap, they are invincible.
Shure:  贼眉鼠眼
Shure: Sneaky look.
Shure:  认贼作父
Shure: Recognize a thief as a father.
Lucia:  对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia:  他就最后总结出人类都太不理性了
Lucia: In the end, he concluded that humans are too irrational.
Lucia:  然后决定消灭人类吗
Lucia: And decided to eliminate humans?
Lucia:  我看了好多类似的科幻片哈哈
Lucia: I've seen so many similar sci-fi movies, haha.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure:  你怎么知道我过一段要去杭州呢
Shure: How did you know I'm going to Hangzhou soon?
Shure:  发现前面就是京杭大运河
Shure: I discovered that ahead is the Grand Canal.
Shure:  我们在杭州
Shure: We're in Hangzhou.
Shure:  是不是能捞上来
Shure: Can we fish it out?
Shure:  是不是又逛回来
Shure: Did we come back again?
Katrina:  啊这边没走过呢
Katrina: Ah, we haven't walked here before.
Katrina:  探索
Katrina: Explore.
Shure: 听到了吧
Shure: Did you hear that?
Katrina:  听到这个是蛤蟆声
Katrina: That was the sound of a frog.
Katrina:  我觉得这个黄绿黄绿的树好看
Katrina: I think these yellow and green trees are beautiful.
Katrina:  没见过好看拍张照
Katrina: I've never seen such beauty, take a photo.
Katrina: 因为 我从来没有见过
Katrina: Because I've never seen it before.
Katrina:  这难道是北方特有的吗
Katrina: Is this unique to the North?
Shure: 有可能吧
Shure: Maybe.
Katrina: 还有那个紫藤萝我们那也没有
Katrina: And the wisteria, we don't have it there.
Katrina: 我们只有石楠花
Katrina: We only have photinia.
Shure: 那个很臭的 吧
Shure: That really smelly one, right?
Katrina:  臭的要命天呐就想呕
Katrina: So smelly, I feel like throwing up.
Katrina:  但不是那种臭
Katrina: But not that kind of smell.
Katrina:  不是跟那种屁一样的臭
Katrina: Not like the smell of farts.
Katrina:  他是那种汗腋下的臭
Katrina: It's the smell of sweaty armpits.
Shure: 我听过它的味道描述
Shure: I've heard it described.
Katrina:  嗯是
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  是那个的味道吧可能吧
Katrina: It might be that smell, maybe.
Katrina:  不太了解很恶心那个味道
Katrina: Not sure, that smell is really disgusting.
Katrina:  什么你说北京
Katrina: What, you said Beijing?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  没见过喜鹊
Katrina: Never seen a magpie.
Shure: 这又好几只呢
Shure: There's quite a few here.
Katrina:  可能我不知道他长啥样吧
Katrina: Maybe I don't know what it looks like.
Katrina:  等等他们
Katrina: Wait for them.
Katrina:  当然当然确确实看到很多乌鸦
Katrina: Of course, I've definitely seen a lot of crows.
Katrina:  我当时我有个北邮的好朋友
Katrina: Back then, I had a good friend at Beiyou.
Katrina:  早上玩的时候北邮海淀那个校区
Katrina: We were playing at the Haidian campus of Beiyou in the morning.
Katrina:  那个外面有一棵树
Katrina: There was a tree outside.
Katrina:  然后在那打车
Katrina: I was getting a taxi there.
Katrina:  打车我一抬头看全是
Katrina: When I looked up, the tree was full of...
Katrina:  我说哎好大鸟
Katrina: I said, wow, big birds!
Katrina:  这什么然后一抬头树上全是
Katrina: What's this? Then I looked up again, the tree was full of them.
Katrina:  就很恐怖
Katrina: It was really scary.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  在那个晚上
Katrina: At night.
Katrina:  突然在看
Katrina: Suddenly looking.
Katrina:  我真的没见过那么大
Katrina: I've never seen such big birds.
Katrina:  一般南方见的都是那种小麻雀
Katrina: In the south, you usually see small sparrows.
Katrina:  麻雀
Katrina: Sparrows.
Katrina: （歌词） 耳朵借我几分钟
Katrina: (singing) Lend me your ears for a few minutes.
Katrina:  什么什么钢胶
Katrina: What kind of steel glue?
Katrina:  这个不是土吗
Katrina: Isn't this soil?
Katrina:  中间是什么
Katrina: What's in the middle?
Shure:  中间这看一下
Shure: Let's take a look in the middle.
Katrina:  我浇水吗
Katrina: Should I water it?
Katrina:  浇什么工
Katrina: What kind of work to water?
Katrina:  建筑材料
Katrina: Building materials.
Shure:  什么东西
Shure: What's that?
Katrina:  不是哈哈哈哈
Katrina: No, hahaha.
Shure:  你在笑什么
Shure: What are you laughing at?
Katrina:  我不是那样的人
Katrina: I'm not that kind of person.
Shure:  你还重复好几遍
Shure: You repeated it several times.
Katrina:  我一直以为是那个建筑材料的钢呢
Katrina: I always thought it was that construction material, steel.
Shure:  我的天呐
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  数据集
Shure: Dataset.
Shure:  不要听这些
Shure: Don't listen to these things.
Katrina: 数据集直接紊乱了
Katrina: The dataset got completely messed up.
Katrina:  识别不出来
Katrina: Couldn't recognize it.
Shure:  说着说着话又说的啊
Shure: Talking and talking again.
Katrina: 奇怪
Katrina: Weird.
Katrina:  这个公园其实可以往里面钻钻钻
Katrina: This park, you can actually explore deeper inside.
Katrina:  当然没有刚刚看的那么小红色是什么
Katrina: Of course, it's not as small as that red thing we just saw.
Katrina:  no climbing
Katrina: No climbing.
Shure:  你好害怕
Shure: You're so scared.
Shure:  你好可怕呀
Shure: You're so frightening.
Shure:  你这个就是就是就是
Shure: You're just, just, just...
Jake: 为啥呀我这一棒槌下去是吧
Jake: Why? If I hit this thing, right?
Shure:  一脸严肃
Shure: With a serious face.
Shure:  然后肩膀就这样走过来
Shure: Then you walk over with your shoulder like this.
Shure:  我爬山
Shure: I climb mountains.
Jake: 来爬山这是什么山
Jake: Come climb the mountain, what mountain is this?
Alice:未名山
Alice: Nameless Mountain.
Lucia:  陡坡路华山
Lucia: Steep Road Huashan.
Katrina:  情人坡
Katrina: Lover's Slope.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:  不知道是哪几个字有诗意的呢哈哈
Lucia: Don't know which poetic words, haha.
Katrina:  紫丁香
Katrina: Lilac.
Katrina:  只在小学课文上
Katrina: Only in elementary school texts.
Katrina:  这不会就是紫丁香吧
Katrina: Could this be a lilac?
Shure: 这个就是对带式它已经枯了
Shure: This is, yes, it's already withered.
Katrina:  哇原来长这样
Katrina: Wow, so it looks like this.
Shure:  当你走近破下爱心般的目光
Shure: When you get close, with a loving gaze.
Katrina:  没见过紫丁香
Katrina: Never seen lilac.
Katrina:  那白的呢
Katrina: What about the white ones?
Alice:白丁香
Alice: White lilac.
Katrina:  白丁香
Katrina: White lilac.
Katrina:  转弯
Katrina: Turn here.
Katrina:  提问我们现在在什么地方
Katrina: Question, where are we now?
Katrina:  AI能看出这个地理
Katrina: Can AI recognize this location?
Shure:  AI会不会以为我们刚刚又回去了
Shure: Will AI think we just went back?
Katrina:  蘑菇蘑菇
Katrina: Mushrooms, mushrooms.
Katrina:  的角落
Katrina: In the corner.
Shure:  我以为你看到蘑菇了呢
Shure: I thought you saw mushrooms.
Katrina:  耳朵借我这几分钟
Katrina: Lend me your ears for a few minutes.
Katrina:  这阳光特别适合拍那种发光发丝
Katrina: This sunlight is perfect for taking glowing hair photos.
Katrina:  发光发丝
Katrina: Glowing hair.
Katrina:  就应该这时间点的阳光拍
Katrina: Should be taken in this kind of sunlight.
Katrina:  我以为我以为这塔是这公园里的
Katrina: I thought this tower was in the park.
Katrina:  雷峰塔
Katrina: Leifeng Pagoda.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  胡说八道
Katrina: Nonsense.
Katrina:  张口就来
Katrina: You're just making things up.
Katrina:  看我今天晚上像养了两只小鸟
Katrina: Look, tonight I feel like I'm raising two little birds.
其他人：哦真的
Others: Oh, really?
Katrina:  这什么东西
Katrina: What is this thing?
Katrina:  是我的衣领吗
Katrina: Is it my collar?
其他人：对
Others: Yes.
其他人：有点像那种小猪耳朵
Others: It kind of looks like little pig ears.
Katrina:  哈哈哈嗯
Katrina: Hahaha, yeah.
其他人：南海的公园
Others: Nanhai Park.
其他人：好热啊
Others: It's so hot.
其他人：我再遇到一个售货机我一定要买那个投币饮料
Others: If I see another vending machine, I definitely want to buy a coin-operated drink.
其他人：我刚刚路过一个就看到了好想买
Others: I just passed one and really wanted to buy it.
Tasha:  我刚刚想买但你们都走远了
Tasha: I wanted to buy it earlier, but you guys walked away.
Katrina:  什么东西啊
Katrina: What is it?
其他人： 就是售货机里有一个饮料
Others: There's a drink in the vending machine.
其他人：我还挺想买的哦哦哦
Others: I really wanted to buy it, oh, oh, oh.
Tasha:  我刚刚看你想买你们都走了
Tasha: I saw you wanted to buy it, but you guys walked away.
Katrina:  哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh.
Tasha:  然后我在那
Tasha: And then I was there.
Katrina:  没事你喊我们就行
Katrina: It's fine, just call us next time.
其他人：下次再遇到我就买
Others: I'll buy it next time I see it.
Jake: 好一会转
Jake: Okay, let's turn.
Jake: 转到最后的这个地方
Jake: Turn to the last spot.
Jake: 然后再多走一段
Jake: And then walk a bit more.
Katrina:  什么饮料好喝吗
Katrina: What drink? Is it good?
其他人：我感觉看着挺好喝一个桃汁
Others: I think it looks pretty good, it's a peach juice.
Shure:  我只想要瓶水就可以
Shure: I just want a bottle of water.
Tasha:  那个桃子饮料汁
Tasha: That peach drink.
Tasha:  我当时在想他是冰的还是常温的
Tasha: I was wondering if it's cold or room temperature.
Jake: 游客中心是吗
Jake: Is it the visitor center?
Jake: 还是会有卖的
Jake: They'll still have it.
Tasha:  然后我就在那等了半天
Tasha: Then I waited there for a while.
Tasha:  然后我开始人脸识别发现识别不上
Tasha: And then I tried facial recognition but it didn't work.
Jake: 卖水的地方
Jake: The place that sells water.
Katrina:  刚进来的地方
Katrina: The place we just came in.
Tasha:  然后开始拿支付宝
Tasha: Then I tried using Alipay.
Lucia:  他们说是一个
Lucia: They said it's a...
Lucia:  那个自动售货机
Lucia: That vending machine.
Tasha:  我发现你们已经走了
Tasha: I realized you guys had already left.
其他人：下次再遇到先买一个
Others: Next time we encounter it, let's buy one first.
Katrina:  你在哪呢
Katrina: Where are you?
Katrina: 牡丹台
Katrina: At Mudan Station.
Katrina:  刚刚进来的地方
Katrina: The place we just entered.
Katrina:  我们刚刚从这进来的吧
Katrina: We just entered from here, right?
Katrina:  这样绕一圈
Katrina: Circling around like this.
Katrina:  还是这这吧
Katrina: Or maybe it's this way.
Jake: 可能是西边
Jake: It might be to the west.
Katrina:  一边进来
Katrina: Entering from one side.
Katrina:  哦我知道了
Katrina: Oh, I get it.
Katrina:  是一个是这样
Katrina: It's like this.
Katrina:  我们是这样子过来的
Katrina: We came this way.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Katrina:  嗯就是从这
Katrina: Yeah, from here.
Katrina:  那我们转一会就进去了
Katrina: Then if we walk a bit, we'll get in.
Katrina:  差不多在这个位置
Katrina: It's roughly in this spot.
Lucia:  所以这俩确实是一个公园
Lucia: So these two are actually one park.
Lucia:  只不过有一个北关大道
Lucia: It's just separated by Beiguan Avenue.
Lucia:  把他们俩隔开了
Lucia: It divides them.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina:  那能出去吗
Katrina: Can we get out?
Jake: 这出去是这是吗
Jake: Is this the way out?
Jake: 这是啥玩意
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 啥也不是
Jake: It's nothing.
Jake: 20号是谁
Jake: Who is number 20?
Alice:堤路
Alice: Dilu.
Jake: 南站道北站道
Jake: South station road or north station road?
Jake: 再转回去买水走
Jake: Let's go back and buy some water.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Tasha:  服从
Tasha: Obey.
Katrina:  let's go
Katrina: Let's go.
Jake: 哈哈这个是蝴蝶诱捕器
Jake: Haha, this is a butterfly trap.
Jake: 你们就过来了是吧
Jake: You guys came over, right?
Jake: 走吧我们绕回去
Jake: Let's go back around.
Jake: 我还有我还有一个裤子是绿色
Jake: I also have a pair of green pants.
Lucia:  这次出来好像没带绿衣服
Lucia: Seems like I didn't bring any green clothes this time.
Lucia:  早知道应该带一条绿裙子
Lucia: I should have brought a green dress.
Jake: 蝴蝶有绿色的吗
Jake: Are there green butterflies?
Shure:  那实在不行我么就换到周三
Shure: If it doesn't work out, we can switch to Wednesday.
Lucia:  对对那个小人是绿色的
Lucia: Yeah, that little guy is green.
Lucia:  小人身边那蝴蝶好像也还真是绿色的
Lucia: The butterfly next to the little guy actually seems to be green too.
Shure:  下周三下周三
Shure: Next Wednesday, next Wednesday.
Lucia:  哎
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:官方好像每个人格都给出来三个形象
Alice: It seems like the official version gives three images for each character.
其他人：哦对一个男的一个女的嗯还有
Others: Oh right, one male, one female, and...
Tasha:  还有个什么
Tasha: And what else?
Lucia:  还有一个中性形象就是
Lucia: And one neutral image, like...
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha:  还有男蝴蝶
Tasha: There's also a male butterfly.
Tasha:  就是跟我们穿的是不一样的是吧
Tasha: It's different from what we're wearing, right?
Alice:啊是的
Alice: Yes, it is.
Lucia:  对就是他的形象会有变化
Lucia: Yes, the image will change.
Lucia:  但是代表的都是这个人格
Lucia: But it still represents the same personality.
Alice:就平时看见EFP竟然是个女的形象
Alice: So usually when I see EFP, it's a female image.
Alice:我一直以为是个
Alice: I always thought it was a...
Alice:像不像男孩
Alice: Doesn't it look like a boy?
Lucia:  哦这样啊
Lucia: Oh, really?
Alice:就快乐小狗好像是女的
Alice: The happy dog seems to be female.
Alice:就给出来的
Alice: The one they gave out.
Alice:比较通用的
Alice: It's more common.
Tasha:  那那你的快乐小狗是男的吗
Tasha: So is your happy dog male?
Jake: 啊这个也分吗
Jake: Oh, is there a difference?
Alice:就是官方是给出来三个形象的
Alice: Yes, the official version gives three images.
Alice:一般只就是我们平时用的只
Alice: Generally, the one we use the most is...
Alice:一个是典型的形象
Alice: A typical image.
Tasha:  water water water water water water
Tasha: water water water water water water
Lucia:  呃不是NTP
Lucia: Uh, not NTP.
Lucia:  是药水是做实验的那个
Lucia: It's the potion for experiments.
Alice:PG是小老头
Alice: PG is a little old man.
Lucia:  啊对对
Lucia: Ah, yes, yes.
Katrina:  前两天测MB
Katrina: A few days ago, I took the MB...
Katrina:  赛发现我变成s人了
Katrina: Test and found out I became an S.
其他人：啊esfp吗
Others: Ah, ESFP?
Katrina: ESTJ
Katrina: ESTJ.
Alice:ESTJ是尺节尺子
Alice: ESTJ is like a ruler.
Lucia:  ESTJ我朋友里好像都没有ESTJ
Lucia: I don't think any of my friends are ESTJ.
Katrina:  他上次不是说没有s吗
Katrina: Didn't he say he wasn't an S last time?
Katrina:  因为因为我是这两天才变成了s
Katrina: Because I just became an S these past few days.
Katrina:  不知道为什么变成
Katrina: I don't know why I changed.
Katrina:  我本来是ENT
Katrina: I used to be ENT.
Katrina:  结果变成了e
Katrina: It turned into an "e".
Katrina:  那就是唯一一个s人了是不是
Katrina: So, is that the only "s" person now?
Jake: 啊你怎么突然变成了s
Jake: Ah, how did you suddenly become an "s"?
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  就是好像在就是来北京前一天测的
Katrina: It's like, I tested the day before coming to Beijing.
Jake: 来北京突然变异了
Jake: You mutated suddenly after coming to Beijing.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 果然是变异
Jake: Definitely mutated.
Lucia:  你看为什么大家加入你的team都会变
Lucia: See, why does everyone who joins your team change?
Jake: 一直在变异
Jake: Always mutating.
Lucia:  就是本来你说紫藤和那个谢斌竹
Lucia: Like you said, Zitong and Xie Binzhu.
Lucia:  都是换了
Lucia: They both changed.
Lucia:  换了发型
Lucia: They changed their hairstyles.
Jake: 噢真的吗
Jake: Oh really?
Lucia:  然后然后现在那个
Lucia: And then now...
Jake: 噢OK OK OK
Jake: Oh OK, OK, OK.
Lucia:  哈哈又有人从n变成了s
Lucia: Haha, someone changed from "n" to "s" again.
Katrina:  对我刚开始没嗯
Katrina: Yeah, at first I didn't...
Lucia:  雨轩真的从n变成了s吗
Lucia: Did Yuxuan really change from "n" to "s"?
Jake: 你们有一个人从P变成J我导致
Jake: One of you changed from "P" to "J" because of me.
Jake: 能理解哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: I can understand, hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Lucia:  实话说我这两天已经有点想要变成g
Lucia: To be honest, I've been wanting to change to "g" for the past two days.
Lucia:  哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha:  因为整个组织的无纪律性
Tasha: Because the whole organization lacks discipline.
Lucia:  哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:  不过也挺好的
Lucia: But it's also quite good.
Shure:  会穿裤子的
Shure: He wears pants.
Lucia:  我喜欢一些随机事件发生
Lucia: I like some random events happening.
Lucia:  就本质上还是很p
Lucia: But in essence, still very "p".
Jake: 这个太这个太P了
Jake: This is too "P".
Jake: 这个太p了
Katrina:  走哪呢
Katrina: Where are you going?
Katrina:  这能这能过去吗
Katrina: Can we get through here?
Lucia:  我觉得我大部分的朋友都是NP
Lucia: I think most of my friends are NP.
Katrina:  我朋友是INFP
Katrina: My friend is INFP.
Katrina:  他说我每一个字母都非常的冷漠
Katrina: He said each of my letters is very cold.
Katrina:  哈哈他说EST这个
Katrina: Haha, he said EST...
Alice:看到就想逃
Alice: Makes you want to run away when you see it.
Lucia:  好像在我的小伙伴里就关系很好
Lucia: Seems like in my small circle, we get along well.
Lucia:  也分人的你只要不是那种很邪恶的
Lucia: It depends on the person, as long as you're not that kind of really evil person.
Lucia:  就是好到大家互相
Lucia: It's about being good to each other.
Lucia:  这种MBTA类型的里面好像没有
Lucia: In this MBTA type, it seems there's none.
Katrina:  但是我闺蜜全是哀人好神奇
Katrina: But all my best friends are introverts, it's amazing.
Lucia: 那就是你一个E人把他们解脱掉了
Lucia: That's because you, an extrovert, have liberated them.
Katrina:  就是我跟哀人能建立那种长期的关系
Katrina: I can establish long-term relationships with introverts.
其他人：其实他们很喜欢那写一对一的交流
Others: Actually, they really enjoy that one-on-one interaction.
其他人：然后呢
Others: And then?
Shure: 我也是哀人
Shure: I'm also an introvert.
Katrina:  真的假
Katrina: Really?
Shure:  因为你刚才说你说完这个我感觉
Shure: Because when you said that just now, I felt...
Shure: 我更像哀人
Shure: I felt more like an introvert.
Katrina:  我之前一直不明白NAS有啥区别
Katrina: I never understood the difference between NAS before.
Katrina:  我之前一直是ENTJ呃
Katrina: I was always an ENTJ, um...
Katrina:  分手那会儿变成了ENFJ
Katrina: During the breakup, I became an ENFJ.
Katrina:  然后变成感性了
Katrina: And then I became more emotional.
Katrina:  然后后来走出来以后又变成ENTJ
Katrina: Then after moving on, I became an ENTJ again.
Katrina:  然后现在变成ESTJ
Katrina: And now I'm an ESTJ.
Katrina:  就是现n是长远
Katrina: N is for long-term...
Katrina:  s是现务实
其他人：N可能是抽象聊天就喜欢聊一些梦想什么星空
Others: N might be for abstract conversations, like talking about dreams and the stars.
Lucia:  哇好热
Lucia: Wow, it's so hot.
Katrina:  是不是往这走
Katrina: Should we go this way?
Shure:  想和你谈论宇宙和天空
Shure: Want to talk about the universe and the sky?
其他人：往哪边
Others: Which way?
Katrina:  不知道往哪边
Katrina: I don't know which way.
Katrina:  反正大体方向应该是往这吧
Katrina: Anyway, the general direction should be this way.
Lucia:  我随机选一条路吧哈哈
Lucia: I'll just randomly choose a path, haha.
Jake: 好好我们听j的
Jake: Okay, let's listen to J.
Katrina:  好的
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 来来石头剪刀布
Shure: Come on, rock-paper-scissors.
Shure: 你赢了就往那边走
Shure: If you win, we'll go that way.
Katrina:  好
Katrina: Okay.
Lucia:  啊我们要分分组走了吗哦OK OK
Lucia: Ah, are we splitting into groups? Oh, OK, OK.
Jake: 没有他们在玄悟
Jake: No, they're still deciding.
Jake: 他们做历史的抉择
Jake: They're making a historical decision.
Lucia:  历史的抉择
Lucia: A historical decision.
Alice:历史的分岔路口
Alice: A historical crossroads.
Jake: 走左还是走右啊
Jake: Left or right?
Katrina:  n既然是讨论那种抽象话题吗
Katrina: So, since N is for discussing abstract topics...
Jake: 没有别的意思哈哈哈
Jake: No other meaning, hahaha.
Lucia:  哈哈这段是不是要剪掉啊
Lucia: Haha, should we cut this part out?
Katrina:  啊我
Katrina: Ah, I...
Katrina:  我感觉我应该是我
Katrina: I feel like I should...
Shure:  你不要瞎问
Shure: Don't ask random questions.
Lucia:  这不要瞎问
Lucia: Don't ask random questions.
Katrina:  我以前是会
Katrina: I used to be...
Katrina:  就是会长一点长远一点的规划
Katrina: Someone who made long-term plans.
Shure:  放在文本里没问题的
Shure: It's fine to put it in the text.
Katrina:  然后现在就是
Katrina: But now, it's just...
Katrina:  之前就近2年看了一些什么疫情啊
Katrina: In the past two years, with the pandemic and all...
Katrina:  核废水啥的
Katrina:  我就觉得过一天是一天吧
Katrina: I just feel like living day by day.
Katrina:  然后我每天就自己给自己找事
Katrina: Every day I find things to do for myself.
Katrina:  每天就很忙
Katrina: I'm always busy.
Katrina:  我就没有办法去想很长远的事情
Katrina: I just can't think about long-term plans.
Katrina:  因为我每天都很忙
Katrina: Because I'm busy every day.
Katrina:  每天都很充实
Katrina: Every day is fulfilling.
Katrina:  然后我觉得每天开心就好了
Katrina: So I think being happy every day is enough.
Katrina:  对我只会定第二天的to do list
Katrina: I only make a to-do list for the next day.
Lucia:  一定要再多加两两多补两刀吗
Lucia: Do you have to add two more cuts?
其他人：那你那个N跟S比分差的不多
Others: Your N and S scores aren't that different.
Katrina:  45-55
Katrina: 45-55.
其他人：哦那差的不多
Others: Oh, not much difference.
Katrina:  因为我看ENTJ跟ESTJ的梗图都很适合我
Katrina: Because the memes for ENTJ and ESTJ suit me well.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina:  真真的确实在感情上就会变成ENFJ
Katrina: Really, in relationships, I turn into an ENFJ.
Katrina:  就会变成保健哥哈哈哈
Katrina: I turn into a health guru, hahaha.
其他人：走到人家小区人家小区好像一个
Others: Walking in their community, their community feels like...
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Mm.
其他人：我喜欢看那种高低有致错落的
Others: I like those with varied heights and layers.
Katrina:  那你去重庆过没
Katrina: Have you been to Chongqing?
其他人：对对对我去过很喜欢
Others: Yes, yes, I've been there and I like it.
Katrina:  我之前老去重庆
Katrina: I used to go to Chongqing a lot.
Katrina:  因为前男友在重庆
Katrina: Because my ex-boyfriend was there.
其他人：啊
Others: Ah.
Katrina:  我特别喜欢重庆这城市很有意思
Katrina: I really like Chongqing, it's a very interesting city.
Katrina:  你你在因为因为我在很老去
Katrina: Because I used to go there a lot...
Katrina:  然后就不会总是打卡景点啥的嘛
Katrina: I didn't always visit the tourist spots.
Katrina:  然后就走在他们那个呃
Katrina: I just walked around their...
Katrina:  小道居民区啊什么
Katrina: Little residential areas and stuff
Katrina:  哎就很有就很不一样的感觉
Katrina: It's just got a very different vibe
Katrina:  重庆
Katrina: Chongqing
其他人：嗯是的
Others: Yeah, it does
Katrina:  重庆比成都更有特色我觉得
Katrina: I think Chongqing has more character than Chengdu
其他人：我看那房子坐落在山上然后高高在上
Others: I saw those houses sitting on the hills, towering above
Katrina:  嗯但那边确实不好
Katrina: Yeah, but it's actually not easy
Katrina:  穿带跟的鞋容易崴脚
Katrina: Wearing heels there, you'll easily twist your ankle
Katrina:  我姐去第一天就崴脚
Katrina: My sister twisted her ankle on the first day
Katrina:  呵呵
Katrina: Haha
Katrina:  波光粼粼唉
Katrina: Sparkling waves, wow
Katrina:  这谁在种菜吗这是
Katrina: Is someone planting vegetables here?
Katrina:  我也是
Katrina: Me too
其他人：他要滚下去
Others: He's going to roll down
Shure:  先在上面滚一圈对
Shure: Roll around on the top first, yeah
Shure:  有人要滚一圈吗
Shure: Anyone want to roll around?
其他人：他要滚下去
Others: He's going to roll down
Katrina:  滚呗3
Katrina: Just roll
其他人：你的眼镜可那什么了还是算了吧
Others: Your glasses might break, better not
Jake: 算了
Jake: Forget it
Lucia:  为什么要从这诡异起来
Lucia: Why does it have to be so weird?
Jake: 等不录的话你可以滚下去
Jake: If we're not recording, you can roll down
其他人：因为草坪可能舒服
Katrina:  想滚
Katrina: I want to roll
Shure:  我说眼镜看好我我给你
Shure: I'll hold your glasses, I'll give them back to you
Lucia:  你把眼镜放到这录着你自己滚下去
Lucia: Put your glasses here, record yourself rolling down
Shure:  算了别污染数据集了
Shure: Forget it, don't mess up the data set
Shure:  然后以为人类的行动方式有一个是滚
Shure: And then they think one way humans move is by rolling
Alice:请你圆润的滚开
Alice: Please roll away smoothly
Lucia:  不是
Lucia: No
Jake: 就是他
Jake: That's him
Lucia:  这是早早期人类撒欢的珍贵记录
Lucia: This is an early precious record of humans frolicking
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 就是从此以后就是
Jake: And from then on
Jake: 呃如果一个人想到那边
Jake: If someone thinks to go there
Jake: 然后就会Rick man的一个滚下去的做法
Jake: They'll think of Rick man's way of rolling down
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really
Jake: 哈哈哈哈这样效
Jake: Hahaha, that's how it goes
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 确实
Shure: For sure
Jake: 率更高哈哈哈
Jake: The rate is higher, hahaha.
Lucia:  这是人工智障吧这是
Lucia: Is this artificial stupidity?
Shure:  因为你看咱们刚才走了一个陡坡
Shure: Because you see, we just walked up a steep slope.
Shure:  然后咱们走的时间可能就是很慢
Shure: And the time we took was probably very slow.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  但是现在它录到了
Shure: But now it recorded that.
Shure:  我从这到那个下坡滚下去时间更快了
Shure: I rolled down from here to that downhill much faster.
Lucia:  啊所以
Lucia: Ah, so...
Lucia:  当给出的指令是计算最快路线的时候
Lucia: When the instruction is to calculate the fastest route...
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:  就会滚
Lucia: It just rolls.
Shure:  一直以为
Shure: Always thought...
Katrina:  计算最短路径直接从草坪滚
Katrina: Calculates the shortest path by rolling straight across the lawn.
Jake: 哎抄近道然后走的话晚上他就给我
Jake: Hey, if you take a shortcut, and then walk, at night it will give me...
Alice:高德地图不管我能不能过去
Alice: Gaode Map doesn't care if I can get through.
Alice:反正他就给我一个穿墙的选项
Alice: Anyway, it just gives me a wall-passing option.
Alice:是不是也是这样的
Alice: Isn't it like that too?
其他人：着是不是就是运河的一部分
Others: Isn't this part of the canal?
Jake: 穿墙 这不行
Jake: Passing through walls, that's not possible.
Katrina:  对这好像是北运河
Katrina: Yeah, this seems to be the North Canal.
Lucia:  那个应该是他数据没及时更新
Lucia: That's probably because the data wasn't updated in time.
Lucia:  就是他不知道哪封 上
Lucia: It doesn't know where is blocked.
Jake: 对这是不够智能
Jake: Yes, it's not smart enough.
其他人：我们高中就像一个城墙那样
Others: Our high school was like a city wall.
Jake: 就是滚下去是可以实现的
Jake: Rolling down is achievable.
Jake: 穿墙是不可实现的
Jake: Passing through walls is not achievable.
其他人：然后周围都有一圈护城河
Others: And there was a moat around it.
其他人：我们老师就说谁不听话就把他从护城河上丢下去
Others: Our teacher used to say, if anyone misbehaves, they would be thrown into the moat.
Katrina:  哈哈那人家会游泳的哈哈
Katrina: Haha, but they would know how to swim, haha.
其他人：啊对呀
Others: Ah, right.
其他人：也构不成什么威胁
Others: So it doesn't really pose any threat.
Shure:  这就是梯田是吗
Shure: Is this a terraced field?
Shure: 梯形的田吗
Shure: A terraced field, right?
其他人：哎你知道有那种表格
Others: Hey, do you know those charts...
其他人：就是什么混乱邪恶混乱中立
Others: Like chaotic evil, chaotic neutral...
其他人：然后什么什么也算梯田那种
Others: And so on, like a terraced field.
其他人：再晒一会我鱼尾纹都要长出来了
Others: If I stay in the sun any longer, I'll get crow's feet.
Katrina:  什么纹
Katrina: What feet?
其他人：鱼尾纹就这样眯眼睛就会长鱼尾纹
Others: Crow's feet. Squinting like this gives you crow's feet.
Katrina:  哦哦居然是这样吗
Katrina: Oh, really? Is that how it works?
其他人：是的
Others: Yes
Katrina:  那那他如果这样子动一动就会长
Katrina: So if he moves like this, it will grow.
Katrina:  这么容易长纹的话
Katrina: If it's so easy to get wrinkles,
Katrina:  那确实
Katrina: Then indeed,
Katrina:  那种稍微爱笑一点就是法令纹很深
Katrina: Those who love to smile a bit more will have deep smile lines.
Katrina:  我法令纹就很深
Katrina: My smile lines are very deep.
其他人：我也是
Others: Me too.
Lucia:  我现在不是不是巴萨的球迷了
Lucia: I'm not a Barca fan anymore.
Lucia:  也不是不是
Lucia: Not really.
Lucia:  就是还没有到路转不是
Lucia: I'm not completely off the bandwagon.
Lucia:  也没有到粉转黑的程度
Lucia: I'm not a hater either.
Alice:第一个为所欲为
Alice: First up, do whatever you want.
Lucia:  就粉转路吧
Lucia: Just turned neutral.
Alice:下一个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Next, hahaha.
Lucia:  因为这两年管理太混乱了
Lucia: Because the management has been so chaotic these past two years.
Katrina:  接什么怎么玩
Katrina: What's next, how do we play?
Alice:成语接龙
Alice: Idiom chain game.
Katrina:  卡边龙
Katrina: Card edge dragon.
Shure:  维他命C
Shure: Vitamin C.
Katrina:  成语接龙
Katrina: Idiom chain game.
Alice:为所欲为
Alice: Do whatever you want.
Lucia:  我正在试图找一个新球队
Lucia: I'm trying to find a new team.
Shure:  维他命 c
Shure: Vitamin C.
Lucia:  现在目前的备选是阿森纳
Lucia: Currently, my backup choice is Arsenal.
Katrina:  一开头只能想到脏话
Katrina: The first thing that comes to mind is profanity.
Katrina:  不好意思
Katrina: Sorry.
Alice:维他命c也能是成语吗
Alice: Can vitamin C be an idiom?
Katrina:  呵呵CNMD
Katrina: Haha, CNMD.
Katrina:  cos
Katrina: Cosplay.
其他人：为了看他是男生还是女生
Others: To see if it's a boy or girl.
Shure:  让他们去打猎吧
Shure: Let them go hunting.
Katrina:  好帅
Katrina: So handsome.
Shure:  给AI看看人类早期打猎
Shure: Show AI the precious footage of early human hunting.
Shure:  的珍贵影像
Shure: It's valuable.
其他人：我感觉要走出去了
Others: I feel like we're going out.
其他人：不知道是哪
Others: Not sure where though.
Katrina:  不知道喂
Katrina: No idea, hey.
Katrina:  这草坪真的好适合打滚
Katrina: This lawn is perfect for rolling around.
Jake: 但前面是有卖东西的地方吗
Jake: But is there a place to buy stuff up ahead?
Katrina: 不 知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Tasha:  社区便利店
Tasha: Community convenience store.
Jake: 像吗这个像吗
Jake: Does this look like it?
Jake: 社区便利店确实是
Jake: It really does look like a community convenience store.
Katrina:  但得翻墙啊
Katrina: But we have to climb over the wall.
Shure:  但是他有没有可能在墙那里面呢
Shure: But is it possible that he's inside the wall?
Tasha:  让他伸出来
Tasha: Let him reach out.
Tasha:  爷爷给我一瓶水
Tasha: Grandpa, give me a bottle of water.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 对这个
Jake: Yes, this one.
Jake: 对啊得有一个包嘛
Jake: Yeah, we need a bag.
Katrina:  这是什么花
Katrina: What kind of flower is this?
Katrina:  这我没见过
Katrina: I've never seen this before.
Katrina:  我感觉北方跟南方的见植物
Katrina: I feel like the plants in the north and south are...
其他人：真的不一样
Others: Really different.
Katrina:  完全不一样
Katrina: Completely different.
其他人：是的
Others: Yes.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  长见识了
Katrina: Learned something new.
Katrina:  现多少度我看看
Katrina: What's the temperature now? Let me check.
Shure: 都快渴死了
Shure: I'm almost dying of thirst.
其他人：我也是啊
Others: Me too.
Shure: 我看见那个水我现在就想下去来一口
Shure: When I see that water, I just want to go down and take a sip.
Katrina:  30度
Katrina: 30 degrees.
其他人：30度
Others: 30 degrees.
Shure: 多少
Shure: How much?
Katrina:  现在30度
Katrina: It's 30 degrees now.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Katrina:  我还带了加绒卫衣呢
Katrina: I even brought a fleece hoodie.
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 这确实出不去对吧
Jake: We really can't get out, right?
Tasha:  便民空间
Tasha: Convenience space.
Tasha:  里面没有便民超市
Tasha: There's no convenience store inside.
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  这没有口
Katrina: There's no exit here.
Katrina:  那前面是不是口啊
Katrina: Is that an exit up ahead?
Katrina:  前面是不是就是门出去
Katrina: Is that the door to go out?
Shure:  应该是
Shure: It should be.
Lucia:  还有乒乓球估计
Lucia: And maybe some ping pong balls too.
Jake: 那这也
Jake: This as well...
Katrina:  耳朵
Katrina: Ears.
Tasha:  哎但这有卖水的门口
Tasha: Hey, but there's a water vendor at the entrance.
Katrina:  那好像能出去
Katrina: It seems like we can go out.
Katrina:  出去就过来
Katrina: Go out and come back.
Katrina:  应该这种修的这种道都会用
Katrina: Roads like this are usually used.
Lucia:  有被晒到
Lucia: Got sunburned.
其他人：现在我门算是野餐完毕了
Others: Now we've pretty much finished our picnic.
Shure:  算
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  算吧
Katrina: Pretty much.
Shure:  我们的野餐
Shure: Our picnic.
Katrina:  我只是只会做大概的计划
Katrina: I can only make rough plans.
Katrina:  我跟我朋友出去玩就是大
Katrina: When I go out with my friends, it's like...
Katrina:  每个人列一个你想特别特别想去的
Katrina: Everyone lists one place they really want to go.
Katrina:  然后其他的就随便就好了
Katrina: And then the rest is whatever.
Shure:  爆掉一个手串
Shure: One of my beaded bracelets just broke.
Shure:  献祭了
Shure: It's sacrificed.
Jake: 还有第二餐
Jake: There's a second meal.
Jake: 其实我们还有几个披萨
Jake: Actually, we have a few pizzas left.
Lucia:  这次喂谁呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Who are we feeding this time? Haha.
Tasha:  还有一盒
Tasha: There's one box left.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们还有一盒披萨
Jake: Haha, we still have one box of pizza.
Katrina:  为人吧
Katrina: For people, I guess.
Katrina:  可以留当晚饭了
Katrina: We could save it for dinner.
其他人：这盒现在都一样的那个彩椒披萨
Others: This box is the same bell pepper pizza.
Lucia:  可是这里没有那个
Lucia: But there's none of that here.
Tasha:  好像是羊肉披萨
Tasha: Looks like it's lamb pizza.
Katrina:  现在小龙虾还挺好吃
Katrina: The crawfish is pretty good now.
Lucia:  没有那个海鸥耶
Lucia: No seagulls here.
Katrina:  海鸥
Katrina: Seagulls.
Jake: 北京竟然没有海鸥
Jake: No seagulls in Beijing.
Tasha:  北京为什么会有海鸥
Tasha: Why would there be seagulls in Beijing?
Lucia:  北京也不靠海吧好像
Lucia: Beijing isn't even near the sea, right?
Katrina:  我身上穿的就是海鸥
Katrina: I'm wearing a seagull.
Tasha:  噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun...
Katrina:  （歌词）耳朵借我
Katrina: (Lyrics) Lend me your ears.
Katrina:  我灯还亮吗
Katrina: Is my light still on?
Katrina:  我是不是该充电了
Katrina: Should I charge it?
其他人：啊是亮的
Others: Ah, it's on.
Katrina:  我要充会电
Katrina: I need to charge my phone for a bit.
Lucia:  我已经为了照顾这个眼镜没有戴大
Lucia: I didn't wear big glasses just to take care of this.
Lucia:  戴了头戴耳机了哈哈
Lucia: I even wore a headset, haha.
Alice:蜻蜓跌水
Alice: Dragonfly touching the water.
Katrina: （歌词）这是 回忆写的歌充满
Katrina: (Lyrics) This is a song written with memories full of...
Shure:  像我们去超市的时候再买水
Shure: Like when we go to the supermarket to buy water.
Jake: 那可能有点这边真的没有水哈
Jake: That might be a bit difficult, there's really no water here.
Lucia:  也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Jake: 这可是居民区的呀
Jake: But this is a residential area.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  要走到小区里
Shure: We have to walk into the community.
Katrina:  刚那便利店
Katrina: That convenience store just now...
Katrina:  只能从这出去再绕回去
Katrina: We have to go out from here and loop back around.
Jake: 对我们偏离路线偏离了一公里
Jake: Yeah, we deviated from the route by a kilometer.
Jake: 哈哈哈没有关系没有关系
Jake: Haha, no problem, no problem.
Shure: 没有关系
Shure: No problem.
Shure: J人带的路
Shure: It was J who led the way.
Katrina:  yeah
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  一定是在J人的计划中吧
Katrina:  yeah是的
Katrina: Yeah, it is.
Lucia:  一定有他的道理
Lucia: There's definitely a reason.
Katrina:  他们在钓鱼哎
Katrina: They're fishing over there!
Lucia:  我们可以沿着它走
Lucia: We can walk along here.
Jake: 我们可以过个马路得了来都来了
Jake: We can cross the street, since we're here anyway.
Lucia: 理论 上说太阳现在是这个方向
Lucia: Theoretically, the sun should be in this direction now.
Lucia:  所以可能都不是很阴凉
Lucia: So it might not be very shady.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Alice:我们不能游过去吗
Alice: Can't we swim over?
Jake: 可以
Jake: We can.
Shure:  但眼镜不防水
Shure: But the glasses aren't waterproof.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Alice:谁会游泳呢
Alice: Who can swim?
Lucia:  其实我会哈哈
Lucia: Actually, I can, haha.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Katrina:  去哪
Katrina: Where to?
Jake: 回头
Jake: Turn back.
Jake: 回到起点
Jake: Back to the starting point.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha:  啊什么
Tasha: Huh, what?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  回到七点远吗
Katrina: Is it far to go back to seven o'clock?
Katrina:  要不要先买水再回到起点
Katrina: Should we buy water first and then go back to the starting point?
Jake: 也可以水在这附近还是
Jake: Sure, is the water nearby or...
Katrina:  水就刚刚那个便利店
Katrina: The water is at that convenience store we passed.
Katrina:  只是从这绕绕出去一下
Katrina: We just need to go around a bit.
Jake: 好那绕一圈
Jake: Okay, let's go around.
Jake: 再绕一圈
Jake: Go around again.
Jake: 把小区给建了
Jake: Build the community.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 光天化日之下我们能干什么
Jake: What can we do in broad daylight?
Katrina:  这应该能进去吧这边
Katrina: We should be able to get in here, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:  拍VLOG吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Let's film a VLOG, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina:  这进不去
Katrina: We can't get in here.
Katrina:  但这应该有有电
Katrina: But there should be power here.
Shure:  如果我们越来越更近
Shure: If we get closer...
Katrina:  我只我只负责大大
Katrina: I just, I just take care of the big things.
Shure:  你负责大方向
Shure: You handle the big picture.
Katrina:  大嗯
Katrina: Big, yeah.
Katrina:  这进不去
Katrina: We can't get in here.
Katrina:  只能在这看有没有买水的
Katrina: We can only see if there's water for sale here.
Katrina:  这应该有吧
Katrina: There should be, right?
Jake: 有超市好强啊
Jake: There's a supermarket, that's great.
Katrina:  哎呀附近是居民区
Katrina: Oh, it's a residential area nearby.
Katrina:  这啥店呀
Katrina: What kind of store is this?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  哦超市超市
Katrina: Oh, a supermarket, supermarket.
Katrina:  想吃雪糕
Katrina: I want to eat ice cream.
Katrina:  呼应了我的网名
Katrina: It matches my screen name.
Katrina:  呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
Katrina:  但是我应该是不能呵呵
Katrina: But I probably shouldn't laugh, hehe.
Alice:你最近会在北京待吗
Alice: Are you going to stay in Beijing for a while?
Lucia:  嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia:  我要是在北京待我还得专门租个房子
Lucia: If I stay in Beijing, I'd have to rent a place.
Jake: 秒啊竟然有个大超市
Jake: Wow, there's actually a big supermarket.
Katrina:  北冰洋北冰洋
Katrina: Arctic Ocean, Arctic Ocean.
Alice:那你是这个结束之后先回家还是
Alice: So, are you going home after this or...
Lucia:  我现在是这样想的
Lucia: This is what I think now.
Katrina:  我喝什么呢
Katrina: What should I drink?
Lucia:  不过我也有可能需要在北京办点事情
Lucia: But I might need to handle some things in Beijing too.
Lucia:  所以不是很确定
Lucia: So I'm not very sure.
Katrina:  我喝营养快线
Katrina: I'll drink a nutrition drink.
Alice:有无怡宝有看到了
Alice: Have you seen any Yibao water?
其他人：这个报销吗
Others: Can we get reimbursed for this?
Jake: 呃可以报吧
Jake: Uh, yeah, I think so.
Jake: 你们扫吧
Jake: You guys scan it.
Alice:有人喝矿泉水吗
Alice: Does anyone want mineral water?
其他人：怎么付一起付还是单付
Others: How do we pay, together or separately?
Katrina: 一起
Katrina: Together.
Shure: 一起付还是单付啊杨老板
Shure: Together or separately, Jake?
其他人：我们一起付还是单付
Others: Are we paying together or separately?
Jake: 一起付
Jake: Together.
Alice:好你要哪个
Alice: Okay, which one do you want?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 帮我选一个吧
Jake: Help me choose one.
Lucia:  你有选择恐惧症吗
Lucia: Do you have decision anxiety?
其他人：遇事不决吃个苦咖啡
Others: When in doubt, go for bitter coffee.
Jake: 谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 这个就算了
Jake: Nevermind, not this one.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 我知道我可以say no
Jake: I know I can say no.
其他人：苦咖啡
Others: Bitter coffee.
其他人：重来重来
Others: Do it again, do it again.
其他人：这是我以为西红柿
Others: I thought this was a tomato.
Lucia:  我觉得值得试试东鹏特饮
Lucia: I think it's worth trying Dongpeng Special Drink.
Lucia:  困了累了喝东鹏特饮
Lucia: Tired? Drink Dongpeng Special Drink.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：6块钱一斤是5块8毛8
Others: Is it 6 yuan per pound or 5.88 yuan?
Lucia:  啊哎
Lucia: Ah, hey.
Lucia:  咱们的一样啊
Lucia: It's the same for us.
其他人：我以为西红柿这个这个
Others: I thought this was a tomato, this, this.
其他人：15一斤 8块7
Others: 15 yuan per pound, 8.7 yuan.
Lucia:  你知道薇薇选的是什么
Lucia: Do you know what Tasha chose?
其他人：刚刚上西红柿要了价钱
Others: Just asked for the price of tomatoes.
Lucia:  说不定我们三个都一样
Lucia: Maybe the three of us got the same thing.
其他人：哎这不对 22块5
Others: Hey, this isn't right, it's 22.5.
Lucia:  哎对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Jake: 薇薇还没选
Jake: Tasha hasn't chosen yet.
其他人：静待她拿哦她没有拿这个
Others: Wait for her to take it. Oh, she didn't take this one.
Lucia:  他拿了尖叫
Lucia: He took the scream.
Shure:  顾客取消之
Shure: Customer canceled it.
其他人：几瓶
Others: How many bottles?
其他人：123456
Others: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
其他人：32一共
Others: 32 in total.
Jake: 啊扫的这么快
Jake: Wow, that was scanned quickly.
其他人：32 35
Others: 32, 35.
Jake:  OK行
Jake: Okay, fine.
Jake: 我怎么付你
Jake: How do I pay you?
Jake: 我扫这个行
Jake: Can I scan this?
其他人：行
Others: Sure.
其他人：开喝
Others: Let's drink.
Jake: 35
Jake: 35.
其他人：嗯
Others: Yeah.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 呃走
Jake: Uh, let's go.
其他人：微信收款35元
Others: WeChat payment received, 35 yuan.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Katrina:  你拿我营养快线干啥
Katrina: Why did you take my Nutri-Express?
Katrina:  哈哈哈惊呆了
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm shocked.
Shure:  拿我脉动干什么
Shure: Why did you take my Pocari Sweat?
Katrina:  你拿我营养快线
Katrina: You took my Nutri-Express.
Katrina:  我以为我记记记错了
Katrina: I thought I remembered wrong.
Shure:  而且我还没没什么反应
Shure: And I didn't even react.
Katrina:  真的
Katrina: Really.
Katrina:  嗯我不是拿营养快线吗
Katrina: Yeah, wasn't I holding Nutri-Express?
Jake: 一个7新币的水
Jake: A 7-dollar water.
Jake: 哈哈哈也可以
Jake: Hahaha, that works too.
Katrina:  慢点慢点慢点
Katrina: Slow down, slow down, slow down.
Shure:  怎么说下一站吗
Shure: So, next stop?
Katrina:  回到起点
Katrina: Back to the starting point.
Katrina:  下一站去哪
Katrina: Where's the next stop?
Katrina:  要不直接在这打车也行
Katrina: Or we could just take a cab here.
Jake: 也行啊下一站去哪啊
Jake: That works too. Where's the next stop?
Katrina:  买东西啊
Katrina: To buy stuff.
Shure:  我们找找个好打车的地
Shure: Let's find a place where we can easily get a taxi.
Alice:买什么调料跟什么肉啥来着
Alice: What seasoning and meat do we need to buy again?
Shure:  这这应该不好打车
Shure: It's probably not easy to get a taxi here.
Jake: 呃不好意思
Jake: Uh, sorry.
Jake: 去哪买啊
Jake: Where should we buy it?
Shure:  找一个大一点的
Shure: Let's find a bigger place.
Shure:  商超吧还是
Shure: Maybe a supermarket?
Alice:有没有那种什么食材
Alice: Is there any kind of food...
Alice:批发
Alice: wholesale market?
Alice:市场那种直接带串好签的不也行吗
Alice: The kind that already has skewers ready to go, wouldn't that work too?
Tasha:  一旦我发起这个话题你就会很认同
Tasha: Once I bring up this topic, you will definitely agree.
Tasha:  小蝴蝶是这样的
Tasha: That's how Little Butterfly is.
Alice:碳油刷子
Alice: Charcoal, oil brush.
Katrina:  菜市场
Katrina: Farmers' market.
Katrina:  大超市
Katrina: Big supermarket.
Shure:  搜一搜勾人
Shure: Search for one.
Tasha:  嗯很凉快
Tasha: Hmm, it's really cool.
Katrina:  这200米居然有个盒马先生
Katrina: There's actually a Hema 200 meters away.
Katrina:  200米居然只有
Katrina: Only 200 meters away.
Jake: 不一定有电
Jake: It might not have electricity.
Shure:  四四四百米
Shure: Four, four, four hundred meters.
Katrina:  400米有个河马先生
Katrina: There's a Hema 400 meters away.
Jake: 走吧走
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  去盒马是吗
Katrina: We're going to Hema, right?
其他人：去盒马可以把晚饭解决了
Others: Going to Hema can solve our dinner.
Shure:  走带路
Shure: Let's go, lead the way.
Katrina:  那就盒马
Katrina: Then Hema it is.
Katrina:  直接买那个肉
Katrina: Buy that meat directly.
Katrina:  然后烤肉
Katrina: Then barbecue it.
Jake: 还有对
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Tasha:  那还回公园吗
Tasha: Are we going back to the park?
Jake: 不回了不回了吧
Jake: No, let's not go back.
Katrina:  （歌词）是为你写的歌出漫天
Katrina: (Lyrics) This song is written for you, appearing all over the sky.
Katrina:  哇终于找到这首歌
Katrina: Wow, finally found this song.
Katrina:  一直哼哼哼哼
Katrina: I've been humming it all the time.
Katrina:  我刚刚不是一直哼这一句吗
Katrina: Wasn't I just humming this line?
Katrina:  我说什么歌来
Katrina: I was wondering what song it was.
Katrina:  北京麦当劳是真多呀
Katrina: There are really a lot of McDonald's in Beijing.
Katrina:  感觉到处都是麦当劳
Katrina: Feels like they're everywhere.
Shure:  我们要不要去打电玩哈哈哈
Shure: Should we go play some video games? Hahaha.
Shure:  抓个娃娃
Shure: Let's catch a doll.
Katrina:  可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Katrina:  老板能不能批100经费
Katrina: Boss, can you approve a 100 budget?
Katrina:  这是彩虹吗
Katrina: Is this a rainbow?
Katrina:  哎这烧烤店能不能问他买
Katrina: Hey, can we ask this BBQ place to sell to us?
Shure:  哈哈哈不行
Shure: Hahaha, no way.
Katrina:  你说我们跟您隔这么远
Katrina: We're so far from you,
Katrina:  又没有竞争
Katrina: there's no competition.
Katrina:  我们又不用做商业用途
Katrina: We don't use it for commercial purposes.
Katrina:  卖我们吧
Katrina: Sell it to us.
Katrina:  成全一个年轻人的开心
Katrina: Make a young person happy.
Shure:  我们要自己动手丰衣足食
Shure: We need to do it ourselves to be self-sufficient.
Katrina:  那你穿哈我我吃
Katrina: Then you wear it, and I'll eat.
Alice:我的儿子怎么在这
Alice: Why is my son here?
Shure:  我们不穿
Shure: We won't wear it.
Shure:  我们烤片吧
Shure: Let's grill slices instead.
Lucia:  哦蛙儿子
Lucia: Oh, my son!
Katrina:  烤片那肉是不是得先腌呢
Katrina: To grill slices, don't we need to marinate the meat first?
Katrina:  我靠这炉子也要v的
Katrina: Wow, this grill needs fuel too.
Katrina:  他开玩笑
Katrina: He's joking.
Katrina:  （歌词）多借我这几分
Katrina: (Lyrics) Lend me these few minutes.
Katrina:  噢这还不是B1啊
Katrina: Oh, this isn't B1 yet.
Katrina:  好特卖去不去
Katrina: Alright, do you want to go to the sale?
Shure:  这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Jake: 哎我们先
Jake: Hey, let's first
Jake: 我我们我们先在商场里边整点活吧
Jake: Let's first do some activities in the mall.
Katrina:  便宜货
Katrina: Cheap stuff.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 先晃悠晃悠
Jake: Let's wander around first.
Jake: 然后再买东西再提走对
Jake: Then we can buy things and take them with us, right?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure.
Shure:  我们去小米买点电电池哈哈哈
Shure: Let's go to Xiaomi to buy some batteries. Hahaha.
Katrina:  还有好特卖呢
Katrina: There's also the sale.
Lucia:  哦好特卖
Lucia: Oh, the sale.
Katrina:  我最喜欢买
Katrina: I love shopping the most.
Katrina:  好特卖好特卖好特卖好特卖
Katrina: Sale, sale, sale, sale.
Lucia:  对对对因为比较便宜
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes, because it's cheaper.
Jake: 好好特卖是什么
Jake: What is this sale about?
Katrina:  便宜货呵呵呵
Katrina: Cheap stuff, haha
Lucia:  那个特价店对对对
Lucia: That discount store, yeah yeah
Jake: 哦哦好
Jake: Oh, okay
Katrina:  就是他都是那种临期的
Katrina: It's all about the near-expiry stuff
Katrina:  但是对于我们就很熟
Katrina: But we're very familiar with it
Jake: 我我们好像还没对齐
Jake: We don't seem to be synchronized yet
Jake: 现在甚至现在
Jake: Even now, even now
Jake: 对一下把把把他叫过来来来来
Jake: Align it and call him over, over, over
Katrina:  come on
Katrina: Come on
Shure:  哦我们出发的时候忘看这个
Shure: Oh, we forgot to check this when we set off
Jake: 对没看这个东西对好
Jake: Yeah, we didn't check this thing, okay
Jake: 3:47 行
Jake: 3:47, alright
Katrina:  那我要去买包卫生巾
Katrina: Then I need to buy a pack of sanitary pads
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia:  他居然挂在外面
Lucia: He actually hung it outside
Lucia:  顺手拿出我的魔法剪刀
Lucia: Casually took out my magic scissors
Lucia:  哈哈魔法剪刀
Lucia: Haha, magic scissors
Jake: 抓一次多少钱
Jake: How much does it cost per try?
Katrina:  看看
Katrina: Let's see
Katrina:  一块钱一个币
Katrina: One token per try
Katrina:  3块钱一次
Katrina: 3 tokens per try
Katrina:  微信购币 89购100
Katrina: Buy tokens with WeChat, 89 for 100
Jake: 100个币是什么意思
Jake: What does 100 tokens mean?
Jake: 100个币抓几次
Jake: How many tries for 100 tokens?
Alice:他们有的是3个币
Alice: Some need 3 tokens
Katrina:  就这种 33个币玩
Katrina: This kind, 33 tokens to play
Tasha:  可能抓30次吧
Tasha: Maybe 30 tries?
Alice:有的5个币
Alice: Some need 5 tokens
Alice:这种抓一次
Alice: This one needs one try
Tasha:  30次吧
Tasha: 30 tries maybe
Shure:  3个币左右
Shure: Around 3 tokens
Jake: 那我100个币你们你们自由分配
Jake: Then I'll let you guys distribute the 100 tokens freely
Katrina:  好
Katrina: Okay
Katrina:  好吧那就微信购
Katrina: Alright, then let's buy with WeChat
Jake: 好吧好行
Jake: Alright, okay
Katrina:  是不是便宜点
Katrina: Isn't it a bit cheaper?
Shure:  呼呼
Shure: Hoo hoo
Jake: 怎么哦好行
Jake: How, oh, okay, fine
Katrina:  就扫这个嘛那89
Katrina: Just scan this, 89
Shure:  扫
Shure: Scan
Katrina:  耶老板万岁哈哈
Katrina: Yay, long live the boss! Haha
Shure:  每人夸一句杨哥好帅
Shure: Everyone say something nice about how handsome Jake is.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Katrina:  付款的瞬间最帅
Katrina: He's the most handsome when he's paying.
Alice:有那个大众点评哎
Alice: Oh look, there's Dazhong Dianping.
Alice:不对那叫啥来着团购
Alice: No, wait, what's it called... group buying.
Jake: 100个币889是吧
Jake: 100 coins for 889, right?
Tasha:  这个会不会便宜一些
Tasha: Would this be cheaper?
Katrina:  这应该是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Katrina:  抖音套餐
Katrina: A TikTok package.
Katrina:  嗯然后再哇
Katrina: Hmm, and then, wow.
Jake: 哦不然还得剪是吧
Jake: Oh, otherwise we have to cut it, right?
Jake: 又是一个离谱的数据
Jake: Another absurd number.
Katrina:  这多少
Katrina: How much is this?
Jake: 对吧
Jake: Right?
Katrina:  84 他这89
Katrina: 84, but this says 89.
Katrina:  应该差不多吧
Katrina: Should be close enough, right?
其他人：老板觉得5块钱不是钱
Others: The boss thinks 5 bucks is nothing.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Shure:  来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on.
Alice:一人抓两把得了
Alice: Everyone grab two handfuls.
Katrina:  抓娃娃去
Katrina: Let's go catch some dolls.
Lucia:  是多少个啊
Lucia: How many are there?
Katrina:  你会抓娃娃吗
Katrina: Can you catch dolls?
Shure:  开玩笑高玩好吗
Shure: Are you kidding? I'm a pro.
Katrina: 这我没抓到过
Katrina: I've never caught one before.
Jake: 我我们我们也抓去
Jake: We, we, we'll try too.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们也抓吧
Jake: Hahaha, let's catch too.
Katrina:  看有什么好看一点
Katrina: See if there's anything nice.
Katrina:  哇还有零食
Katrina: Wow, they even have snacks.
Katrina:  这好丑啊
Katrina: This is so ugly.
Katrina:  我看看你会吗
Katrina: Let me see if you can do it.
Katrina:  抓出了什么
Katrina: What did you catch?
Jake: 抓什么呀
Jake: What did you catch?
Katrina:  没有看看
Katrina: Nothing, let's see.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：这个更可爱了
Others: This one is even cuter.
Katrina:  这个有点
Katrina: This is a bit...
Katrina:  他会甩耶别掉
Katrina: He might swing it, don't let it drop.
其他人：差一点
Others: So close.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  掉了没了
Katrina: It dropped, it's gone.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina:  哎呦表演才艺了
Katrina: Oh, showing off some skills now.
Katrina:  看看拿多少分
Katrina: Let's see how many points.
Katrina:  哦有点东西啊
Katrina: Oh, there's something here.
Katrina:  棒也掉
Katrina: The stick also dropped.
Katrina:  这边边上有点难
Katrina: It's a bit hard at the edge here.
Katrina:  试一下
Katrina: Try it out.
Katrina:  这卡
Katrina: It's stuck.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  再试一个
Katrina: Try one more.
Katrina:  啊哎
Katrina: Ah, hey.
Katrina:  但是他一直在边上你知道吗
Katrina: But it's always at the edge, you know?
Katrina:  就搞得很心动
Katrina: It's really nerve-wracking.
Katrina: 再来一次
Katrina: Try again.
Katrina:  哎哈哈哈
Katrina: Oh, hahaha.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  啊这不是哎哎哎
Katrina: Ah, this isn't... hey hey hey.
其他人：哎哎哎
Others: Hey hey hey.
Katrina:  哇啊哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Wow, hahaha.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina:  牛啊哈哈
Katrina: Amazing, haha.
Jake: 啊这么厉害
Jake: Ah, so impressive.
Katrina:  哈哈装饰屋子有了
Katrina: Haha, now we can decorate the house.
Jake: 对啊装饰公司
Jake: Yeah, for the decorating company.
Jake: 挺好挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good.
Katrina:  节省成本耶啊
Katrina: Saving costs, yay.
Jake: 你抓了吗
Jake: Did you catch it?
Katrina:  这是我人生中第一次抓到娃娃
Katrina: This is the first time in my life catching a doll.
Katrina:  对我要给他拍一张
Katrina: Yeah, I need to take a picture.
Katrina:  帮我拿下衣服
Katrina: Help me take off my clothes.
Alice:醉了一下
Alice: A bit dizzy.
Alice:再来一次吧
Alice: Try again.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  士气大增
Katrina: Morale boosted.
Katrina:  哈哈好
Katrina: Haha, good.
Katrina:  给AI提供了宝贵的素材
Katrina: Provided valuable material for the AI.
Katrina:  这也好可爱
Katrina: This is also so cute.
Alice:他好松啊这个爪
Alice: His paw is so loose.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:不行我还要这个我不信
Alice: No way, I want this. I don't believe it.
Katrina:  还有别人
Katrina: There's someone else.
Katrina:  这怎么玩
Katrina: How do you play this?
Katrina:  这抓抓罐子吗
Katrina: Is this for grabbing the jar?
Katrina:  哦不对操纵机器抓住小球
Katrina: Oh no, you control the machine to grab the ball.
Katrina:  小球落稳后
Katrina: Once the ball is steady...
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  抓零食试试
Katrina: Try grabbing some snacks.
其他人：你是不是直接看中 这个然后就抓到他
Others: Did you spot this and then grab it right away?
Katrina:  一直抓
Katrina: Just keep grabbing.
Katrina:  持之以恒的追求哈哈哈
Katrina: Persistent pursuit, haha.
Katrina:  还有傻可爱
Katrina: And silly cute.
Katrina:  我觉得这也可爱
Katrina: I think this is cute too.
Katrina:  这也不知道好不好抓
Katrina: Not sure if this is easy to grab.
Katrina:  噗噗一直想要一个噗噗来着
Katrina: Poopoo always wanted a Poopoo.
其他人：啊要三个你有吗
Others: Ah, you need three, do you have them?
Katrina:  有3个刚好 3
Katrina: I have three, just three.
Katrina:  不知道质量好不好哎试一下
Katrina: Not sure about the quality, let's try.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
Katrina:  其实这种角上会不会它甩也容易甩出
Katrina: Actually, on the corners, it might fling out easily.
Katrina:  哈还分析的头头是道了起来
Katrina: Haha, you're analyzing it so well.
Katrina:  笑死
Katrina: Hilarious.
Katrina:  啊这只夹子张的好大
Katrina: Ah, this clipper opens so wide.
Katrina:  你看好家伙
Katrina: Look, oh my.
其他人：往后去一点点对
Others: Move back a little bit, yeah.
其他人：没有没有
Others: No, no.
Katrina:  啊哎呀
Katrina: Ah, oh no.
Katrina:  吓我一跳
Katrina: Scared me.
其他人：就会松一下
Others: It will loosen a bit.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 还有啥玩的
Katrina: What else is there to play?
Alice:多出来一个币
Alice: An extra coin.
Alice:谁还有用
Alice: Anyone else need it?
Katrina:  我没了一个也用不了
Katrina: I don't have any left, can't use it.
Katrina:  最后啊确定吗
Katrina: Finally, are you sure?